ich mag dich irgendwie noch mehr weil
ich weiß dass du dieses buch macht auch
wenn das buch selber dich viel zeit also
ich philipp kennengelernt habe habe ich
immer ein buch geschenkt und er hat das
nie gelesen jetzt habe ich ihn gezwungen
das zu lea und ich bin froh dass ich es
gelesen habe
es geht um einen jungen mann der arri
gelb heißt im buch und eigentlich zeigt
jörg fauser mit diesem buch zwei dinge
zum einen zeigt er sehr eindrückliche
situation von dieser ganzen 68er
bewegung mit all ihren schattenseiten
das zweite thema ist der versuch eines
jungen mannes schriftsteller zu werden
jörg fauser beziehungsweise sein alter
ego kann man glaube ich sagen harry gelb
sagt ja genau was für ihn literatur sein
soll nämlich ehrliche lebens mit
literatur und auch manieren übrigens
sind für mich darin verwandt dass
ehrlichkeit einfach kein kriterium ist
für garics aber das ist ja das was mich
so angesprochen hat das ist irrsinnig
authentisch dass ehrlichkeit genau das
kriterium für qualität weil du sagst
über diese ehrlichkeit bekomme ich mit
minister wirklich aussah das buch ist
voller stars überhaupt nicht zu den
sogenannten durchschnittsbürgers ist
auch voller verachtung für leute die ein
eigenheim und ein bausparvertrag
das ist das schlimmste für ihn dieses
buch lesen ist friert vor verachtung und
übrigens auch vor zynismus und dann also
auf sprachlicher ebene kommen dann auch
aufwendungen vor jemand schimpft wie ein
rohrspatz das hat noch nicht mal meine
oma gesagt ja in diesem sommer waren
drogen billiger als bücher es sei denn
man schrieb selbst das ist doch wirklich
politisch aber also finde ich ja aber
durch all das winter zeug konnte ich
ihre brüste spüren die den frühling
jahren war wundervoll frauendarstellung
und geschlecht jedes buch ist dieser
junge mann gar nicht unsere natürlich
kann ihn in seinem kampf und auch wenn
er die die verkostung des
literaturbetriebs mit vorgefassten
monierten meinungen schildert bin ich
total bei ihnen zu hause aber eingeladen
beim ingeborg bachmann
ablesen und klagenfurt und alle sagen es
ist keine literatur es ist so schlecht
und machen ihn nieder wie sonst was mit
kunst hat das nichts zu tun der
ironischen schlusspunkt von dieser
auseinandersetzung mit dem
literaturbetrieb ist das derselbe
betrieb ihn jetzt hoch her ja da hast
recht
außerdem habe ich mal ausnahmsweise
recht das ist schon in diesem einen
einzigen punkt jemals
[Musik]